voici mon gros my life ou monde dessine
ma vie en français mais ça fait un petit
peu nul dessine ma vie quand même je
vais d'abord vous parler de mes parents
qui sont nés juste là en roumanie alors
ne faites pas attention à l'angleterre
qui ressemble à une heure alors la
roumanie s'étaient pas la grosse grosse
ambiance à l'époque puisque c'était la
dictature communiste
mes parents m'ont raconté que là bas on
était obligés d'aller voter
mais pour un seul candidat le dictateur
du coup ça laissait peu de place à
l'hésitation en fait et ma grand-mère
trouvé ça débile donc qu'elle voulait
pas aller voter
mais quand la police est venue elle a
changé d'avis en fait finalement
finalement elle voulait bien mes
grands-parents donc fui la dictature
pour arriver en france où l'ambiance
était quand même meilleur et c'est là
que mes parents se sont rencontrés vous
vous trouvez pas que la roumanie
ressemble un peu à un mémo un laissé
tomber je suis né le 12 mai 1989 à nice
sous les palmiers et les vieux qui
crament au soleil et j'ai un grand frère
ou une petite soeur et un petit frère
qui adore brûler des voitures
non je déconne déconne il adore jouer à
minecraft ça c'est vrai par contre j'ai
toujours été proche de mon grand frère
enfin surtout son point de mon visage on
se chamaillait tout le temps je lui
pincer un peu l'épaule il me casser les
genoux
c'était équitable avec mon grand frère
on était les opposer en quelque sorte
lui c'était un petit peu une terreur ce
qui fait qu'à ma rentrée au collège en
sixième
un surveillant m'a dit on ou encore un
homme très envie d'aller au collège
après ça vraiment alors je sais que dans
tous les drom ilife il faut dire qu'on
était martyrisé à l'école tout ça moi
franchement ça allait bon y'a vie juste
un élève qui s'acharnait sur moi en
sixième mais je revue deux ans après on
avait tous grandi et anne on annonce aux
flux en fait et bah franchement ça l'a
rendu beaucoup plus sympa j'ai jamais eu
une tonne d'amis il était peu mais on
était pareil on adorait créer des trucs
et j'en vois certains encore aujourd'hui
ont passé le week end et nos vacances à
inventer des histoires pour en faire des
bd à faire des sketchs audio à faire de
la musique à créer des jeux / rpg maker
on passait un peu pour des geeks mais on
s'en foutait pas mal à 16 ans j'ai fait
un job d'été dans un magasin de
matériaux de construction en gros je
devais porter des trucs lourd pour des
clients c'était très chiant mais quand
j'avais une minute de libre je prenais
un stylo et je dessinais en cachette sur
les sacs de ciment parfois les clients
me demandaient les sacs avec les dessins
probablement pour faire plaisir mais ça
marche et ça me faisait vraiment plaisir
toutes ces créations que je faisais seul
ou avec mes potes je les mettais sur mon
blog
sauf les sacs de ciment bien sûr et puis
un jour en 2007 j'ai décidé de faire une
vidéo avec le caméscope de mes parents
et de la mettre sur internet
et là c'est le méga buzz ah non ah non
en fait non pas du tout mais c'est pas
grave je voulais juste créer des trucs
et les sites comme dailymotion ou
youtube me permettait de créer des
nouvelles choses alors j'ai continué
j'ai fait des centaines de vidéos
même avec 3 de moyenne en allemand j'ai
eu mon bac j'avais décidé de faire une
école préparatoire économique et
commerciale et on m'a dit non
du coup j'ai fait une fac d'économie à
aix en provence
ce qui me laissait quand même plus de
temps qu'une prépare pour fermer vidéo
sur mon blog et pendant l'année scolaire
willow on me proposait un travail sur
paris
faire des vidéos pour un site
d'actualité alors j'ai beaucoup hésité
genre une seconde et j'ai accepté mes
parents savaient pas trop si c'était une
bonne ou une mauvaise nouvelle
du coup ils m'ont dit si ça marche pas
ton job sur paris tu reprends les études
bien sûr papa bien sûr maman je n'ai
jamais remis les pieds dans une fac
en arrivant sur paris j'ai eu de la
chance puisque j'ai trouvé un petit
duplex de 180 mètres carrés en plein
coeur de la capitale
non je déconne je dormais par terre chez
des potes mais c'était cool aussi
et j'ai surtout rencontré des gens qui
faisaient comme moi des vidéos sur
internet
il y avait des grands des petits des
ados des cheveux lui est encore des
petits et d'un coup on a tout ce buzz et
de ouf
ah non ah non en fait non toujours pas
mais c'est pas grave
à l'époque personne ne se faisait
connaître sur internet ou même gagner sa
vie on fait des vidéos juste parce que
ça nous plaît et progressivement vous
avez été de plus en plus nombreux à
regarder toutes ces vidéos comme coeff
il fallait juste pas abandonné un jour
on m'a proposé de faire mes vidéos sur
une chaîne de télé tous les jours on
puis j'avais carte blanche pouvait pas
refuser et j'avais même réussi à faire
embaucher mon pote maxime muscat pour
m'aider on s'amusait vraiment bien mais
les vidéos sur internet ça manquait et
c'était là où j'étais plus à l'est alors
j'ai arrêté l'émission
puis la chaîne se mettaient à diffuser
les anges de la télé réalité avec délire
et façon pour les connaisseurs
aujourd'hui le caméscope un peu changé
mais je suis toujours sur internet le
week-end que je passais avec mes potes à
créer des trucs c'est devenu mon
quotidien et ça c'est grâce à vous alors
je vous remercie vraiment j'ai plein
d'idées et plein de projets que j'ai
hâte de vous montrer ça c'est dans les
prochaines vidéos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]